[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the family of george floyd speaking out
as jury selection is underway in the
murder trial of derek chauvin
i think you know probably the best way
to describe it is more like a roller
coaster ride
and the ruling reinstating third degree
murder against derek shovin
we break down what the charge means for
his defense and prosecution
plus our experts explain what to look
for in picking a jury
and the millions law enforcement is
spending on security for the trial
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
anjan levy is in minneapolis where jury
selection is underway
in the trial of derek chovin charged in
the murder of george floyd
but first let's get right to the
presidential ruling reinstating the
third degree murder charge
against strovin derek shoven was charged
with second degree murder
second degree manslaughter and third
degree murder trial judge peter cahill
dropped the third degree murder charge
saying there was a lack of probable
cause in february the minnesota court of
appeals upheld the third degree
murder charge in a separate case
involving former minneapolis police
officer mohammad noor
convicted of shooting and killing
australian american justine domond
who called 9-1-1 to report a sexual
assault
then the minnesota court of appeals
ruled cahill aired in dismissing third
degree murder
against chauvin saying the nord decision
was presidential
chauvin's defense appealed to the state
supreme court the high court said
wednesday evening
they would not review the defense's
petition arguments then went back to
trial judge cahill
so judgment has been entered on the
appeal in this case
so i think we can address the merits
defense attorney eric nelson says
chauvin's case
is factually different from north but in
the newark case
mr noor shot his gun across apart
his partner's chest towards the
silhouette that could have been
anyone or anything and so that was
clearly
fit in the universe of depraved mind
danger to others plural
and i think the distinction we made in
the original probable cause order last
fall was
this is a different case it is more
focused on a single person
attorney neil cation joined attorney
general keith ellison's office
to prosecute the case pro bono you know
it isn't necessary that more quote more
than one person was or might have been
but in jeopardy
that's this case uh and so we think you
have the absolute discretion to have
this charge
and we think you should it reflects the
gravity of the offenses
there is no instrumentality here other
than arguably
mr chauvin's knee which is not
inherently dangerous
right judge cahill ruled chauvin will
now again be facing third degree murder
he then took aim at the court of appeals
ruling i think the court of appeals
reaches too far by saying there's plain
language in the rules
there is silence there is not language
prohibiting
or saying that it is entered at judgment
or that it takes effect immediately
but it is silence and i think what the
court of appeals has inferred from the
silence
is that opinions take immediate effect
when filed i accept that
jury selection then resume for day three
angelette levy's in front of the
courthouse for us
to bring us the latest
yeah brian so far six jurors have been
seated
five of them are men and one is a woman
the racial breakdown is three white men
one
black man and one man who identified as
hispanic
the woman has been identified as a
person of color
and also described as multi-racial now
prospective jurors have been asked a
number of questions each one is
questioned for about
one hour each time they're asked
everything from their feelings about
black lives matter and whether or not
they attended protests
they've also been asked have they
watched the video of george floyd's
death
and the news coverage of his death and
the civil unrest and protests that
followed
even when the video surface like all
you're going to see is
the the picture of him neil and george
floyd's
neck or stuff like that the media just
just puts things a little higher than
what what they are
you can separate what you may have seen
in the media
from the evidence in this case
yes do you think that to some degree
your opinion about this case that you
have coming in here today
was influenced by the media a little bit
yeah but
like i said i asked i still need to see
the bigger picture evidence
okay witnesses and all that there's more
to that than just one media shows
and that really seems to be one of the
things that the defense seems to be
preparing for that they're going to
hammer on the media coverage of this
case
and the fact that everybody has seen
maybe the video of george floyd passing
away but maybe they don't have all of
the information
that's relative relevant especially
relevant to the defense case
and i want to mention today for the
first time we actually
heard a juror social media account and
something they posted on social media
about george floyd's death and visiting
the area we actually
saw that brought up by the defense to
call into question the impartiality
of one of the potential jurors and that
potential juror ended up being stricken
by the defense brian thanks angeanette
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney imran ansari and terry austin
imran these questions are running the
gambit and when i say questions i mean
the voir d or jury selection questions
or they're running the gambit of black
lives matter
blue lives matter protest property
damage how important is it
to see how the people feel about these
topics before trial
sure brian it's extremely important
because when you have a case that has
gained
so much media attention and has brought
out such
strong feelings in the public you need
to make sure that you have a fair and
impartial juror now even in a regular
case
that is the prime concern of the
attorneys
to get a fair and impartial juror who's
going to give both sides a fair shake
and is not going to be biased one way or
the other and decide on the evidence
alone
but a case like this with so much media
attention
that is all the more difficult and
that's why these questions need to be
presented to these
prospective jurors to make sure they are
fair and impartial
now terry murder the third degree is
back on what does that mean for the case
you know this is a huge victory for the
prosecution
they've actually been arguing to bring
it back in
ever since the judge kicked it out for
lack of probable cause
and it means now that the jury can
consider
this theory and under this theory it
means that children acted with
a depraved mind and without regard
to human life and it also carries a
sentence
of 25 years so if you add that on
remember the other two charges are still
there
we still have the second degree murder
and we still have the second degree
manslaughter and they carry sentences of
40 and 10 years respectively so
in total he could look at up to 75
years now anjan have you seen a change
in the defense
since the murder of the third degree
charge was reinstated they
asking questions differently you know i
wouldn't say they're asking questions
differently because they still need to
know the answers to the questions
they've been asking all along
it did seem that eric nelson was a
little nervous this morning when arguing
when
against that third degree murder charge
being reinstated but he has continued
with the same line of questioning
about you know if i met you out in a bar
somewhere or at a party what would you
tell me about yourself and
you know questions about the
impartiality and whether or not they
took part in protests and
really going off that questionnaire to
see whether or not
these jurors really feel that they can
put any preconceived notions they have
about the case
aside and decide solely on what's
presented in the courtroom
makes sense still going full steam ahead
thank you still ahead on law and crime
daily our experts weigh in
on how to pick a jury for such a high
profile trial but first
the family of george floyd speaking out
hear what two cousins have to say
as they sit in the courtroom during
derek shovin's trial their advocacy
and floyd's legacy next
[Music]
welcome back in the courtroom in
minneapolis one seat is reserved for a
family member of george floyd because of
coven 19 restrictions
anjanet levy sat down with two of
floyd's cousins who've been closely
following
the jury selection yeah brian sharita
tate
and tara brown have each taken a turn
this week
sitting in that one seat reserved for
the floyd family during jury selection
they say the last nine months has really
been a roller coaster of emotions going
through this as a family
and really with the rest of the world
watching and they say they are working
to do something positive in george
floyd's name
people around the world george floyd is
the man who died on video
in police custody and became a symbol of
a movement to push for police reform
to tara brown and sharida tate floyd is
their beloved cousin i have so many
memories
because obviously we we grew up together
he was always funny
he was a jokester life changed forever
for floyd's family
late last may when cherita tate saw a
story
on the news i saw that and my first
response was
this is so sad i feel really sorry for
this man's family and then of course
maybe five minutes or so later i got the
call saying it was perry
so you know i said okay how did i miss
that
the video went viral sparking protests
and civil unrest in cities across the
country
i don't think there's a person on earth
who would have predicted that it was
gonna
happen this way like that it would
affect the entire world
for the last nine months brown and tate
have been focused on getting to the
trial
there haven't been a whole lot of wins
per se in favor of these kinds of cases
but i have to believe that
this will result in a different outcome
just the
sheer way in which this has moved
forward in
the movement that has started as a
result
derek chauvin's defense maintains that
floyd died of a fentanyl overdose
not from chauvin's actions the fact that
floyd's drug use will be an issue
is painful for the family we expect that
they will
make him out to be you know
somebody that he wasn't or you know just
to
assault his character or whatever just
to
give people a different kind of
impression of him
we're not saying he was perfect and to
remember their cousin
tate and brown have started the george
floyd foundation
we have the three tenets that we're
really working on that's the
uh social justice uh workforce
development and youth services
it's kind of like anything that we can
do that can
uh you know make sure people he has a
legacy
of doing things that are positive within
the community
and and you know we've always been
people that wanted to give back
now both tate and brown said that they
have not made any type of eye contact
with derrick chauvin when they've been
in the courtroom they said they're just
really focused
on the jury selection process and derek
chovin as you can tell is
always taking notes and he is very
focused on this as well
i asked them both whether or not they
would ever say anything to derek chovin
and if they
had the chance what would they say and
tate said
she would say nothing brown said she
would hold back
and not tell him what she was feeling or
thinking
brian thanks back to discuss the trial
of derek shoven in the death of george
floyd
is defense attorney imran ansari and
terry austin terry
for many the death of george floyd is
more than a criminal case
it reignited a movement how do you see
this foundation or these cousins
fitting into the change that comes after
floyd's death
you know i think it's very important
what they are doing they are making sure
that the world
hears about this and the world is
watching you know they want to see
whether or not he's going to be held
criminally responsible
for these actions we've seen laws that
have been passed
making sure that chokeholds aren't being
used we've seen police procedures being
changed but the world is really waiting
to see
whether or not chauvin is going to be
personably
liable for what he has done and you know
this case is of particular interest
also because everyone watched what
occurred
on the video so they're waiting to see
what happens
talking about what everyone watched
imran the defense is going to argue was
the fentanyl
not shoving's knee that killed george
floyd with a video that graphic do you
think that's a strong defense
well defense is going to have to back up
that assertion
with uh hard scientific evidence and
with that video where you see the force
of
boy's neck it's going to be a difficult
story to sell that's why they're going
to have to rely
on the science the levels of fentanyl in
the blood system and expert testimony
that they're going to present to say
that it wasn't the pressure that was
applied to the neck
that caused his death but it was a uh
sort of a
abundance of factors including the
fentanyl in his blood system
that would have contributed to his death
makes sense the only defense they
probably have anjanette
have the george floyd's cousins watch
the video
you know i asked them whether they had
seen it and uh tara brown said that she
had
avoided watching it sharita tate said
that she
i think had seen some brief clips and
somebody had sent it to her
inbox right after it happened and she
didn't want to watch it and as you can
imagine i mean it's
it is a difficult video to watch and if
you're a family member
it's even more difficult to watch that
you're basically watching a man die
so i don't think i don't think that they
either one of them are looking forward
to having to see these things in the
courtroom
but neither one of them has been keen on
watching the video
i can't imagine anyone in that family
world it's a truly devastating video to
watch
for anyone yet alone a family member
coming up on law and crime daily the
joint law enforcement effort to provide
security during the trial
plus how many and who will sit on the
jury
in the trial of derek showman the
questions the answers and the ones who
made it to the jury
[Music]
next
we're back so what exactly should
attorneys be looking for in these
potential jury members
we asked jury consultant expert alan
turkheimer just that
you bring in people that represent what
the jury looks like you match the
demographics you say okay kind of
county is 80 white and then you want to
get a range of age occupations and get
them in there alan turkheimer is the
founder of the litigation consulting
firm trial methods
he says jury selection is one of the
most important phases of any trial
but will be key for both the prosecution
and defense of derek chovin
from the defense perspective in a case
like this you really want to have people
who can
get past the emotional aspect of the
video
who are thinkers from a logic standpoint
who connect dots who maybe are a little
more methodical in the way they think
so that they don't just see that
horrible video and make up their mind
potential jurors have to fill out a
14-page questionnaire describing how
much they know about the case
and their opinions towards law
enforcement and black lives matter
i think they could probably just look at
the questionnaire look at some of the
responses and think okay we have some
that are
really extreme on one end the pro blm
side and then
the pro police side and some of them i
think could just get tossed they
wouldn't even have to waste their time
bringing some of the jurors in
of course people know about the case of
course they've seen the video at that
point
then they have to really dig in deep and
try to determine whether or not somebody
yes you can still pay attention to the
news but not have a vested interest
for the defense turkheimer suggests
pre-trial strategies
like focus groups mock trials and venue
attitude surveys
i was working for the defense i would
say hey here's a videotape
some videotape of the officer shoving
let's hear his explanation
and let's get some focus group reaction
to it hear what these people have to say
what they expect
do they believe him do they like him
turkheimer says both sides need to look
out for people
who have hidden agendas and are
intentionally trying to get on the jury
also known as stealth jurors you want to
make sure you don't have anybody who
seems too eager to get on
but it's really tricky because these
stealth jurors tend to know
what to say to get on they tend to
moderate or temper their answers
they know to say they should be fair and
impartial
so you have to take a holistic approach
jury selection is scheduled to take
three weeks
opening statements are set for march
29th it's going to be a challenge i
think they can do it given that they
have all this time to pick a jury but
it's certainly going to be a real
a challenge indeed when we come back
what is the city of minneapolis doing to
prepare for the trial of derek shovin
which agencies are involved and how much
it's all going to cost
welcome back the cost for security
during the derek shovin trial could be
in the millions of dollars
and in a plan that began months ago
the minneapolis police department teamed
up with the sheriff's office
state patrol as well as a national guard
to create
operation safety net barricades and
fencing reportedly cost
up to one million dollars and a mutual
aid agreement has cost the city another
1.5 million
the plan provides security in and around
the courthouse as well as creates a safe
place to protest
for the last eight months we have had a
unified command
and the planning has been labeled
operation safety net
these are i'm so very proud of our
mutual aid partners who continue to
be with us along the way to not only
ensure that minneapolis
remains safe and a place where all those
can gather to practice their first
amendment rights
but we are also a metro and region-wide
response in the event it should be
needed
minneapolis police announced the arrest
of a suspect for a deadly shooting days
ago at the george ford memorial site
local reporters say the intersection is
essentially an autonomous zone
where law enforcement is not welcomed
there's the
respect and folks gathering and
utilizing that space
to pay its respects to to mr floyd at
the same time
i'm hearing overwhelmingly from
community members who quite frankly
are feeling hostage over there at the
situation
we cannot allow um for that violence
uh to continue to happen we have to open
up that intersection
and i know that may be difficult for
some people who've been holding space in
there
since last year but we have to open up
that intersection
we have all community city enterprise
been supportive
of a plan to make
the location where george floyd was
killed to never have
vehicular traffic go over it again i'm
talking about the specific location
and we do hope to move forward with a
bump out
to allow for a memorial to be placed
there
here one last time to discuss the
security in the murder trial against
derek chovin is imran ansari and terry
austin
imran how important is security for the
lawyers the defendant the jurors and
the trial itself brian it's really
important because you want the
attorneys on the case to feel
comfortable you want the jurors to feel
safe and comfortable
you don't want them distracted meaning
the jurors
as they hear the evidence in this key
case and make a decision
so security is an immensely important
because it's not only protecting
those involved in the trial but it's
also protecting those members of the
public
who are gathering to peacefully protest
make sense terry let's ask the obvious
question
is this too much for a city to dish out
for a trial
absolutely not you know one of the
things i always say is you gotta do what
you gotta do
and i listened to the mayor's press
conference this morning and i think the
measures he's taking
make complete sense he wants to make it
a safe environment
he wants the businesses to thrive and he
said he wants to make sure that there's
a memorial for george floyd
so i think he's spending the money he's
doing the right thing he's making sure
it's safe
and he doesn't want this autonomous zone
because you know you won't you don't
want to keep anyone out
makes sense be sure to check out the law
and crime network for gavel to gamble
coverage of the derek chauvin trial
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you